jennifer lopez was just spotted in miami
florida with ben
affleck and the 51 year old triple
threat is
all smiles i'm thrilled the former exes
were snapped on a walk together
sunday that's j-lo grinning ear to ear
as the 48 year old oscar winner walks
behind her
i love it the two famously known as
benifer
recently rekindled their romance years
after they split in 2004.
ben was spotted visiting jen's la home
on multiple occasions
and the two even took a trip to montana
with a source telling e.t
they are quote having fun together the
source added quote
jen is loving the attention she has been
getting from ben
jen and ben didn't get along at the end
of their relationship
years ago but once their hurt feelings
subsided
they were friendly for many years now
that they've fully reconnected
they are having fun together and care
about each other a great deal
you know i can't stop smiling the two
first started dating back in 2002
while starring in their first movie
together julie
i'm sorry do we know each other not yet
they
quickly got engaged but by 2003 they
called off their wedding just
days before their planned september
ceremony and they officially split
in january 2004 it was my first like
adult heartbreak was it because
it was so public and we wanted to know
every single
thing about your relationship and health
i was an adult we were about to get
married
it didn't work out and it was just a bad
heartbreak
like you know just one of those breakups
that really you know
it was like a tough one for me jayla
went on to marry mark anthony whom she
shares
13 year old twins max and emmy with but
they split in 2014
after 10 years of marriage and in 2019
she got engaged to former mlb star alex
rodriguez after two years of
dating but they called off their
engagement in april
she's really funny and amazing and
she's just magical she you know she
everything she touches is just
i've learned so much from her in such a
short period of time as for the former
mlb star
he took to his insta story on sunday to
open up about new beginnings
quote i am about to step into a new
beginning in my life
anything that doesn't serve me is
clearing out of my life
new energy is emerging new levels are
unlocking for me mentally physically and
spiritually
i am remaining patient and know that
this new phase of my life
is coming every day you should wake up
with you know let's go follow your
dreams a source previously told et that
a-rod was quote
shocked by how quickly jlo reunited with
ben and a second source tells et that if
a-rod had it his way
he'd still be with jen it was definitely
her call to end it
he would have loved for it to keep going